Joe Celia Lee who often goes by JC Lee
the daughter of the late great marvel
mastermind Stan Lee had some fighting
words for Marvel Studios parent company
Disney after it failed to reach an
agreement with Sony Pictures to keep
spider-man in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Lee spoke with TMZ about the
situation and it's clear that she's not
happy over what she perceives to be a
disney power play to score full control
of Marvel Comics flagship character whom
Stan Lee co-created with Steve Ditko and
for whom Sony has long held the film
rights
she said Marvel and Disney seeking total
control of my father's creations must be
checked and balanced by others who while
still seeking to profit have genuine
respect for Stan Lee and his legacy
whether it's Sony or someone else's the
continued evolution of Stan's characters
and his legacy deserves multiple points
of view
Lee then went on from implying Marvel
Studios did not have respect for Stan
the man's legacy to outright stating it
when my father died no one from Marvel
org Disney reached out to me from day
one they have commoditized my father's
work and never shown him or his legacy
any respect or decency in the end no one
could have treated my father worse than
Marvel and Disney's executives
that's a brutal assessment and frankly
confusing considering that Stan Lee made
cameos in every single Marvel Studios
film up until his death publicly Marvel
head honcho Kevin Feige has never shown
anything but respect for Lee in his
legacy after the icons death last year
Feige said in a statement he was very
special and I've always said anybody who
met Stan I've never heard one story of
somebody meeting Stan Lee and not being
overwhelmed with excitement he never
disappointed and I was lucky enough to
see him about ten days before he passed
away it doesn't seem like he's gone
because just like with Walt Disney on
this lot his influence will never go
away
JC Lee's comments came the same week as
a Sony Pictures statement which painted
the decision to axe the wall crawler
from the MCU
as one which ultimately was made by
Marvel it read we are disappointed but
respect Disney's decision not to have
Feige continued as a lead producer of
our next live-action spider-man film we
hope this might change in the future
but understand that the many new
responsibilities that Disney has given
him including all their newly added
Marvel properties do not allow time for
him to work on IP they do not own inside
sources meanwhile have insisted that the
split is solely over money with Disney
having sought of
your piece of the spider pie going
forward yeah get out here 100 bucks
the ad said 3,000 this struggle over
spider-man is likely far from over
the reported split between the two
Studios which reached their initial
agreement to share custody of Spidey in
2015
caused a massive outcry among fans most
of whom were far more pleased with the
MCU iteration of the character portrayed
by Tom Holland than they had been with
the amazing spider-man franchise which
was considered a commercial and critical
failure of course the failure of the two
Studios to reach an agreement isn't
final the 2015 deal was struck after
talks between Sony and Marvel similarly
fell apart in 2014 a situation that came
to light when a series of internal
emails among Sony execs were made public
and a strong reaction from fans was
undoubtedly a factor which brought the
parties back to the table
Sony maintains that it fully intends to
produce at least two more spider-man
solo film starring Holland with
spider-man homecoming and spider-man far
from home director Jon Watts
also returning these films would
presumably take place in the Sony
universe of Marvel characters which
includes venom that would mean the
wholesale porting of a character from
one shared universe to another totally
unrelated one this has never happened
before
in live-action anyway and it would
obviously present some narrative
challenges to craft a satisfactory
narrative about how in the heck
spider-man zapped to another universe
the studios may have to cooperate at
least very briefly
perhaps prominent voices like Lee's can
prod the two companies to come back to
the bargaining table because splitting
may be more of a headache than it's
worth
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superhero movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you